let's talk about one of the most
important biological processes frankly
if this process didn't occur we probably
wouldn't have life on earth and I
wouldn't be making this video for you
because there would be no place for me
to actually get food and the process is
called photosynthesis photo synthesis
and you're probably reasonably familiar
with the idea if the whole idea is is is
plants and actually bacteria and algae
and other things but we normally
associate it with plants let me make it
in very simple term so we normally
associate it with plants and it's the
process that plants use and we might
have learned this when we were very
young it's a process that plants use to
take carbon dioxide plus some water plus
some water plus some I'll do it in
yellow plus some sunlight plus some
sunlight and turn it into and turn it
into some sugars or some maybe
carbohydrates carbohydrates or sugars
plus oxygen and obviously this has to
vary for profound pieces to it for us as
a living species one we need
carbohydrates or we need sugars and in
order to fuel our bodies you saw that in
the cellular respiration videos we
generate all of our ATP by performing
cellular respiration on glucose which is
essentially a byproduct or a broken-down
carbohydrate it's the simplest one for
us to process in our in cellular
respiration and then the second hugely
important part is getting the oxygen
once again we need to breathe oxygen in
order for us to break down glucose in
order to a respire in order to perform
cellular respiration so these two things
are key key for life key for life
especially for life that breeds oxygen
key for life so this process other than
the fact that it's interesting that you
know we're able to that that there are
organisms around us mostly plants that
are able to harness actual sunlight you
know you have this fusion reactions in
the Sun 93 million miles away and it's
releasing these photons and some small
subset of those photons reach the
surface of earth you know they make it
their way through clouds and whatever
else and then these plants and bacteria
and algae are able to harness that
somehow and turn them into sugars that
we can then eat or maybe the cow eats
them and we the cow if we're not
vegetarians and we can then use that for
energy not that the cow is all
carbohydrates but this is essentially
what is used as the fuel or the energy
for all of the other important compounds
that we this is where we get all of our
fuel so this is fuel for animals fuel
for animals or you know if you eat a
potato directly you are directly getting
your carbohydrates anyway this is a very
simple notion of photosynthesis but it's
not incorrect I mean if you have to know
one thing about photosynthesis this
would be it well let's delve a little
bit deeper and try to get into the guts
of it and see if we can understand a
little bit better how this actually
happens I find it amazing is somehow
photons of sunlight are used to create
these sugar molecules or these
carbohydrates so let's delve a little
bit deeper so in general we can write
the general the general equation for
photosynthesis well I've almost written
it here but I'll write it a little bit
more scientifically specific you start
off with some carbon dioxide you add to
that some water and you add to that
instead of something I'm gonna say
photons because these are what really do
excite the electrons in the chlorophyll
that go down and you'll see that this
process probably in this video and we'll
go in more detail in the next few videos
but that excited electron goes to a high
energy state and as it goes to a lower
energy state we're able to harness that
energy to produce ATP's and you'll see
NADPH is and then those are used to you
produce carbohydrates but we'll see that
in a little bit but the overview of
photosynthesis you start off with these
constituents and then you end up with
you end up with a carbohydrate and the
carbohydrate could be glucose doesn't
have to be glucose so the general way we
can write a carbohydrate is C h2o and
we'll put an N over here that we could
have n multiples of these normally
you'll n will be at least three
in the case of glucose n is six you have
six carbons 12 hydrogen's and 6 oxygen
so this is a general term for
carbohydrate but you can have many
multiples of that you could have these
long chain carbohydrates so you end up
with a carbohydrate and then you end up
with some oxygen and you end up with
some oxygen so this right here isn't so
different than what I wrote up here in
my first overview of how we always
imagined photosynthesis in our heads in
order to make this equation balanced and
so you have n carbons here so I need n
carbons there let's see I have two n
hydrogen's here right Hydra two
hydrogen's and I have n there so I need
two n hydrogen's here so I'll put an N
Out there and let's see how many carbons
I have how many oxygens I have two n
oxygens plus another ends of three and
oxygens let's see I have one n let's see
put an N here and then I have two n and
I think this equation balances out so
this is this is a 30,000 foot view of
what's going on in photosynthesis but
when you dig a little deeper you'll see
that this doesn't happen directly that
these goes this happens through a bunch
of steps that eventually gets us to the
carbohydrate so in general we can break
down photosynthesis I'll rewrite the
word we can break down photosynthesis
photosynthesis and we'll delve deeper
into future videos but I want to get you
the overview first into two stages two
stages we can call one the light
reactions light reactions or sometimes
they're called
the light dependent reactions and that
actually would probably be a better way
to write it let me write it like that
light dependent means that they need
light to occur light dependent reactions
and then you have something called the
dark reactions and that's actually a bad
name because it also occurs in the light
dark reactions I wrote in a slightly
darker color and the reason why I said
it's a bad name is because it still
occurs in the light occurs in light but
the reason why they probably called it
the dark reaction is that you don't need
light or that part of photosynthesis
isn't dependent on photons
to occur so a better a better term for
it would have been light light in
dependent light independent reaction so
just to be clear the light reactions
actually need sunlight they actually
need photons for them to proceed the
dark reactions do not need photons for
them to happen although they do occur
when the Sun is out they don't need
those photons but they need the
byproducts from the light reaction to
occur so that's why it's called a light
independent reaction they occur while
the Sun is out but they don't need the
Sun this needs the Sun so let me make it
very clear let me so this requires
sunlight
this requires photons this requires
photons and and let me let me just make
a very brief overview of this this will
maybe let us start building a scaffold
from which we can dig deeper so the
light reactions need photons and then it
needs water so water goes into the light
reactions and out of the other side of
the light reactions we end up with some
molecular oxygen so that's what happens
in the light reactions and I'm going to
go much deeper on what actually occurs
and what the light reactions produce it
produces ATP which we know is the the
cellular or the molecular or the
biological currency of energy it
produces ATP and it produces na dhih pH
now when we studied cellular respiration
we saw the molecule NADH NADPH is very
similar you just have this P there you
should have this phosphate group there
but they really perform similar
mechanisms that when you have that this
agent right here this molecule right
here is able to give away now let's
think about what this means it's able to
give away this hydrogen and the electron
associated with the hydrogen so if some
if you give away an electron to someone
else or someone else gains an electron
that something else is being reduced
right let me write that down
a good reminder oil rig right oxidation
is losing an electron reduction is
gaining an electron your charge is
reduced when you gain an electron right
it has a negative charge so this is a
reducing agent it it gets oxidized by
losing the hydrogen and the electron
with it I have a whole discussion on the
biological versus chemistry view of
oxidation but it's the same idea when I
lose a hydrogen I also lose the ability
to hog that hydrogen's electron so this
right here when it reacts with other
things
it's a reducing agent it gives away it
gives away this hydrogen and the
electron associated with it and so the
other thing gets reduced so this thing
is a reducing agent reducing agent and
what's useful about it is when this
hydrogen and especially the electron
associated with that hydrogen goes from
the NADPH to say another molecule and
goes to a lower energy state that energy
is also B it can be used in the dark
reactions and we saw in cellular
respiration the very similar molecule
NADH that that through the Krebs cycle
or actually more important that through
the electron transport chain was able to
help produce ATP why is that as that as
it gave away its electrons and they went
to lower energy states but I don't want
to confuse you too much so the light
reactions you take in photons you take
in water it spits out oxygen and it
spits out ATP and nadph that can then be
used in the dark reactions and the dark
reactions for most plants we talked
about it's called the Calvin cycle
Calvin cycle and I'll go into a lot more
detail of what actually occurs in the
calvin cycle but it takes in the ATP the
NADPH and it produces it produces it
doesn't put direct ly produce glucose it
produces a well you probably saw this if
you could call it P gal you could call
it G 3 P these are all stands for let me
write these down this is
this is phosphoglyceraldehyde let me
write that down
phospho phospho glitter glyceraldehyde
my handwriting broke down or you could
call it glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate let
me write that down
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate same same
exact molecule you can almost imagine it
is this is a very gross
oversimplification as three carbons with
a phosphate group attached to it with
the phosphate group attached to it but
this can then be used to produce other
carbohydrates including glucose if you
have two of these you can use those two
to produce glucose so let's just take a
quick overview again because this is
super important I'm going to make videos
on the light reactions and the dark
reactions those will be the next two
videos I make so photosynthesis you
start with photons now all of these
occur when the Sun is out but only the
light reactions actually need the
photons the light reactions take photons
we're going to go into more detail what
actually occurs and it takes in water
oxygen gets spit out ATP and nadph gets
spit out which are then used by the dark
reaction or the calvin cycle or the
light independent reaction because these
still occur in the light they just don't
need photons so they're the light
independent reaction and it uses that in
conjunction we'll talk about other
molecules that are used in conjunction
and I've used I forgot a very important
a very important constituent of the dark
reaction in it needs carbon dioxide
that's where you get your carbons to
keep producing these
phosphoglyceraldehyde Zoar
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate so that's
super important it takes in the carbon
dioxide the the the the products from
the light reactions and then uses that
in in the calvin cycle to produce this
very simple building block of other
carbohydrates and if you remember from
glycolysis you might remember that this
pee gal molecule or this g3p same thing
this was actually the first product when
we split glucose in two when we
performed a glycolysis so now
we're going the other way we're building
glucose so that we can split it later
for energy so this is an overview of
photosynthesis in the next couple of
videos I'm actually going to delve a
little bit deeper and tell you about the
light reactions and the dark reactions
and how they actually occur